Hello Freak bitches.
Just because we're trying to sell you the best shit possible at the lowest price
possible.
That is the number one goal with on it and everything we sell you is shit.
We use kettle bells.
No scarves.
Yeah,
mom against old dudes with scarves and like it was big Randy coture fan,
but he's been wearing a scarf lately and I just want to talk to him.
Randy couture was such a bad one.
The fucking to turn it around his night,
who cares about like it being a leotard and I'd still be like stay away from it.
He could go out to clubs with a real legitimate albatross around his neck and
you wouldn't care.
Speaking of which,
did you see Matt Mcconney and Magic Mike?
No,
I missed that.
I never met anybody who wouldn't have sex with themselves more that guy.
Oh God.
I mean he,
I guarantee you.
Jerks.
Officer's highlight reel.
He basically has just stock footage of him stretching his character or Matt
mcconaughey talking about,
Hey,
the human,
how do you watch these actors?
It's like,
why didn't you take that role and take that role?
You took that role so you could wear outfits and go and go.
That's what he does.
And then I,
I've never seen it very well.
Now I have to go see it.
Dude.
It's a bigger issue.
We're talking about the commercials.
We let's,
let's talk about,
sorry,
sorry.
Sorry.
Cause I need to know about this cause I saw the ad for that and I got a little
panicky.
Oh No.
Yeah,
it's,
we're so gay that I was like,
what's going on here?
What is this?
Tatum,
Tatum O'Neal or whatever the guy's name is.
He's awesome,
handsome fella.
He couldn't look better.
Oh,
handsome.
This guy.
I hung out with him in Vegas for a weekend and women literally stopped just
obviating and his presence and he's a great guy.
They must panic.
There's certain types of comedy where,
you know,
you and I were talking also about how,
what a privilege it is to feel it,
to be a headliner and to be somebody who gets to perform all of the country.
And like sometimes I look at it,
I was in Miami and Fort Lauderdale and I just,
you know,
it was a,
I did,
I got at one point,
I just had them going pretty strong and I just looked at it.
I was like,
I felt like the luckiest human being in the fucking world.
That's why when I watch Matt Mcconahey fucking Magic Mike and he's fucking
leather chest girdle and it's fucking hot pants and any and he's coming off
stage.
I did it.
Hey,
hey yoker boy,
come fucking do 10 minutes of stand up.
You fucking idiot.
I don't jump off stage like I just did an hour and a half and crush.
Somebody hugged me hard so I can kiss your mouth.
This animosity,
I'm attracted to him.
All right.
I mean,
I hate him.
I mean I hate him.
No,
I was just thinking about how you know,
you're,
you're an actor and you,
you have five scenes in a movie and be like,
Whoa,
you were great in that movie.
[inaudible]
collectively are probably doing 10 or 15 minutes of actual activity.
Whereas when you do stand up,
you're up there for,
you know,
it's just a different,
it's just a different thing.
It feels,
it feels a little,
why would you care though that he wants to be?
Cause I mean him so much and as a matter what's going on now.
I just saw the movie and I was just,
I was just looking at,
I'm going,
you're just,
you took this movie just so you could wear those outfits and biggest Boehner.
Did he?
He,
he did.
If I was,
if I was gay,
I would definitely,
he's a very attractive man.
Would you choose,
I appreciate Mike.
All Channing Tatum.
Really?
That's my boy,
right?
You Kid,
he's got a full mouth.
Best genetics.
He's got thick lips.
Nice skin.
The eyes on him.
The cat eyes seems confident too.
He's a great guy.
He's got a big car.
Sense of humor.
Jesus were both released something.
Joe Rogan and Brock Callen gays and gets talking about Channing Tatum was so,
did you want you to send that one that just came out of here?
I bet he's got a big dot on a big cock.
Did you,
did you watch the,
the actual whole movie?
Yeah,
because,
yeah,
because I wanted to know myself more and more.
Although I thought the movie was good and I liked that.
I liked,
I liked Channing Tatum.
I mean I had my hands.
That movie looks so gay that I was flipping through the channels.
I was flipping through the channels and I saw it.
It popped up and I went,
Whoa,
change a quick like,
you know how you're flipping through like you have preview,
next preview.
I get in a hotel,
it was chilling at a hotel and there's like,
I was like,
this is so gay.
I can get it off.
Like dudes were like s gyrating back and forth.
Which by the way,
I don't think women like that.
I think that motion is really just isolated.
Someone Riding Dicks.
I don't think that,
I know gyrating like the way a guy's doing it.
Women like the rusting,
they like to get fucked.
They don't,
they want you,
you're are you Dick Riding circled man.
Dick Riding,
sweaty circle moon.
Makani he's doing,
he's got a fucking a leather thong and he's doing back bends and shaving and,
but the character I was watching,
I was,
what bothered me was I was watching,
I go,
you know,
um,
that's an actor.
If I took that role there,
there's a lot.
I do have that role.
Maybe,
but I wouldn't because there's not a lot to do like he played at just one note.
Shut the fuck up bitch.
She would take that role on a god heart.
You and Channing Tatum and your underwear can,
that guy would be your boyfriend.
He be carrying around like he was crossing the,
the wedding nuptials I would look like I have fucking rickets next to that guy,
so I don't want to deal with,
do the movie with him.
No,
dude,
you would do it.
So shut the fuck up.
You've given Matthew Mcconaughey a hard time and you're doing the movie.
Maybe he just wanted to meet Jenny channel to
Matthew.
I'm sorry,
I don't mean to put you down.
He's kind of like a nice enough guy.
I hear he's a very nice guy.
Yeah.
Here's the Nice car.
It doesn't mean he's not really vain and not an annoying,
well,
listen man,
he's playing a part.
How could you like if you judged me based on the movies,
zookeeper,
you'd push ups by the fucking conveyance in Malibu.
He does with his shirt off.
No,
it doesn't.
It does.
If I see you and you're doing pushups in front of the pavilion in Malibu,
I'm going to take your back.
That's right.
I'm going to take you back and I'm going to get their hooks in my fryer.
Just kick him in the ribs.
I'm just going to hold.
He can scream all you want.
You shouldn't have been doing pushups.
Do that with a knapsack on,
with a knapsack on and a Bandana.
Wah Wah tourists take pictures of you.
Is that what he was doing?
That annoys me.
He wanted to be really fit for this movie.
Maybe it was like something he was white working on.
Like what kind of exhibitionist could he become because he was playing a part in
a movie,
man.
Did you murder?
He could look,
think about liquid.
What's his name does when he does.
Um,
uh,
Daniel Day Lewis,
when he gets immersed in a role,
I mean he's unbelievably immersive.
Maybe that's where Matthew mcconaughey was done.
It was just being a douchebag.
He's playing a Douche bag in the movie man.
And that's douchebag activity.
Have the role was in so much of a Douche bag.
The role was more of a,
just think he's supposed to be the club owner,
but you'll see what I mean.
Would it be okay if he did pushups in a way,
in a place where nobody could say like say if it was like his,
there was like some grass in front of his car and nobody could see and he
dropped down for a quick 15.
Here's the box.
That's what bothers me.
There I am.
And here's what bothers me.
If you work out just for the sake of vanity to and then,
and then,
and then when I,
when I see what you're doing is just,
you're just sculpting for,
for to be a peacock.
I understand.
I,
I get,
I get staying in shape and there's something about it.
If it's not for something functional,
it was not for something like that you're doing.
I immediately,
I'm just saying,
you can do it.
You're not my friend.
That's all.
I said.
Why is that?
What about a guy who's just doing like bench presses and curls never touches the
legs.
Just wants to look good in a tight shirt,
but it he's doing it.
You know what you know?
You know why I like that?
Well,
I've got no problem with that.
He's doing it so we can go out and get laid on a Saturday night.
Fucking,
Hey God bless you.
What do you think Nancy?
What kind of haze doing when he's wearing leather underwear doing that so he can
fucking get the the dailies and jerk off to himself.
That's why he's fucking doing it and there's a difference.
I see Matt mcconahey doing a role like that and Magic Mike all,
I'm seeing something masturbatory I watched Channing Tatum.
He's trying to do something.
He's actually playing a character who's fucking conflicted about being a 30 year
old stripper and it's fucking great.
Mcconahey is is.
It's a masturbatory performance.
He's watching himself.
He's not trying to do anything.
He's not trying to express anything that's he's trying to play.
I mean the guy has shown a pretty broad range of gray in the world.
No,
Miriam,
I don't want to marry him,
but it was really good and contact the house going on.
He was all right.
He was good in contact.
I enjoyed him.
I thought he was sensitive without town.
Seemed like the type of guy that would fall in love with Jodie foster.
That was a long time ago.
Um,
who the fuck?
Why didn't you watch that?
I don't know what happened to you.
I was robbed on your head.
Is Cal on Mrs Kellen Warner to watch and he's blaming it on wow.
Oh,
I might have to get high and watch it,
but I'll probably get really scared.
I'll probably have to get my blankie.
You get a little jealous and you better be inside of a pussy when you watch it
all the time.
I don't have that kind of stamina or desire of,
I was about sex or will.
That's why you need to give a fuck.
I got tricked early on in life and I figured it out.
Now I'm,
I'm fine.
Just beaten off and then going about my business all mine.